this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles
unlimited access starts just 2 dollars
99 and you get 30 days of free if you
sign up a curiosity stream dot-com /by
graphics using the code
byah graphics more on them in a bit
[Music]
there was a period in history between
1898 in 1922 dubs the heroic age of
Antarctic exploration it marked a time
when daring adventurers set their sights
on one of the few lands that still
escaped humanity's reach the Antarctic
and this lands was harsh cold and
unforgiving and all the people who dared
face this unknown knew that there was a
good chance that they might not come
back
generally seventeen expeditions are
considered part of this era which made
legends of men such as Ernest Shackleton
Douglas Mawson and Robert Falcon Scott
and then of course there was raw
Amundsen the man we will be talking
about today as the leader of the very
first expedition to reach the South Pole
Amundsen secured his spot as one of the
greatest explorers in history but that
was just one of his polar adventures as
Amundsen was the type of man designed to
explore the frozen wilds forever roll
angle Brecht gravan Inge Amundsen was
born on July 4 16th 1872 in the
Norwegian parish of Borge near the
capital of Oslo which back then was
called Kristiania he was the youngest of
four sons of Jen's Engel Bertha Munson
and Hannah Gustavo salvus he was part of
a well-off maritime family who ran a
shipping business which at its height
operated 22 vessels soon after a Rolls
Bertha family relocated to Oslo where
the four boys grew up both parents
wanted roll to get a good education his
mother in particular wanted him to avoid
life at sea all together and actually
become a doctor but a young role grew up
with stories of famous adventurers and
explorers and he wanted to emulate them
in school he heard the tale of
Franklin's Lost expedition how British
explorer John Franklin set off to find a
way to traverse the Northwest Passage
and never
and from again the Northwest Passage is
a sea route that connects the Atlantic
and Pacific Oceans by passing through
the Arctic Archipelago for centuries
chanting this passage was a Holy Grail
for European sailors as it represented a
new and faster route to Asia but many
failed in their attempts to safely
navigate it Franklin set off with two
ships the HMS Erebus
and the HMS terror and vanished search
attempts were all in vain and it wasn't
until only a few years ago that both
wrecks were finally located Amundsen
dreamt of succeeding where Franklin
failed then in 1889 the 17-year old role
was in the crowd to witness the glorious
return of another great Norwegian
explorer Fridtjof Nansen after he became
the first to traverse the interior of
Greenland Amundsen knew that one day he
wanted to be a polar explorer just like
his heroes speaking of which you can
probably expect to see preach off Nansen
featured in his own biographic Svidler
in the future but getting back to
Amundsen he was torn between two
decisions on one hand his life's
ambition was to become an explorer on
the other he promised his mother that he
would study medicine in the end he felt
that it was his duty to obey his
mother's wishes
so in 1890 he enrolled in the Royal
Norwegian Frederick University of
Kristiania to become a doctor however
when his mother died in 1893 are all
entered his studies and set off on his
true passion it was probably for the
best though not only did Amundsen ends
up becoming one of the world's greatest
explorers but it was unlikely he would
have ever graduated from med school as
he always had terrible grades and showed
little aptitude for book learning
their senior Amundson sent off on his
first adventurous ski tour over the
Hardanger mountain plateau with two
other men
lorenzi assured a land vilhelm Holst the
inexperience of the skiers became
evident and the trio had to abandon the
journey
it wasn't until five years later that
Amundsen attempted the ski tour again
this time successfully accompanied by
his older brother Leon of course in
order to become a proper Explorer a life
on land would not suffice
Rolle also had to master sailing
therefore in 1894 he obtained his first
berth as an ordinary seaman aboard a
seal hunting ship called the Magdalena
this vessel was later renamed the
Danmark and was used by danish explorer
Ludvig malleus Eriksson in 1906 in his
ill-fated expedition to charter the
unknown northeast coastline of
Greenland's a mission which cost him his
life and the lives of his two senior
officers as a sailor Amundsen performed
his work admirably and quickly rose
through the ranks two years later he got
his first opportunity at a true polar
adventure when he was taken on as a mate
aboard the RV belgica for the Belgian
Antarctic expedition captained by
Belgian Navy officer Adrian girl Ashe
this voyage was a scientific missions of
the Antarctic incidentally it is also
considered to be the first adventure of
the aforementioned heroic age of
Antarctic exploration role Amundsen was
not the only future Explorer aboard the
vessel though the ship's physician was
an American named Frederick cook he Anna
Munson struck up a lifelong friendship
and cook would later achieve his own
Fame or should we say notoriety when he
claimed to be the first person to reach
the North Pole his claim was challenged
while his main rival Robert Peary and
the question of who actually reached the
geographic North Pole first is still
unsettled and highly controversial but
we'll have more on that a little bit
later as far as the Belgian expedition
was concerned things were far from
smooth sailing the crew of the Belcher
had became the first people to spend the
winter in the Antarctic this wasn't by
choice but rather because the ship
became trapped in pack eyes in the
belling's house and see the Belgica and
its crew were stuck in these icy
conditions for thirteen months including
two months of perpetual darkness some of
the men including Dougal Asheville
gravely ill with scurvy
while others began losing their sanity
it wasn't until the start of 1899 that
they finally drifted near a stretch of
open water it was still hundreds of
yards out of reach so the men had to saw
and dynamize through their icy prison
for a month in order to create a channel
for the ship to be able to move into the
expedition finally reached the Belgium
capital of Antwerp on November the 5th
1899 where the men received a hero's
welcome despite the many hardships the
Belgian Antarctic expedition was
actually considered a success as the
crew collected a lot of scientific data
and discovered many new islands moreover
it left him on sand confidence enough
that he was ready to lead his own
expedition and he obtains the
endorsement of his hero free Jaffa
Nansen indeed he often gave the young
Explorer advice and even on occasion
helped in secure financing as far as his
objective was concerned Amundsen was not
one for half-measures even though it was
his first time as a captain he wanted to
fulfill his greatest ambition navigating
through the Northwest Passage it was
something that had been attempted many
times but never succeeded all the way
moreover it was something very dangerous
which had claimed the lives of explorers
far more experienced than a Munsen that
being said the Norwegian explorer didn't
simply plunge into this mission
headfirst and hope for the best
he did his homework in 1900 Yves is
determined scientist and polar explorer
George run Newmar who taught him what he
knew about the planet's magnetic field
and how it affected instruments at the
poles while the geographic North Pole is
the northernmost point on earth from
which all directions point south the
magnetic north pole moves around all the
time thanks to changes in the planets
core
in fact according to modern estimates
ever since its formal discovery by
British explorer James Clark Ross in
1831 the magnetic north pole has
traveled around 1,400 miles Amundsen
didn't need that kind of uncertainty
when heading in the right direction
could make the difference between life
and death
next up Amundsen needed a ship they
wanted something small and sturdy but it
also had to be cheap because he didn't
have a lot of funds at his discretion in
the end he opted for a 45 tons Lube
could cure it was much smaller than any
other ship that had been used in the
Northwest Passage before but Amundsen
felt its flexibility and increased
maneuver
suited his purposes moreover he also
intended to use a small crew of only six
people
by comparison Franklin's Lost expedition
had two ships and a hundred and
twenty-nine crewmen but Amundsen
concluded this was one of the missions
fatal flaws as it severely stretched
their limited resources moreover it was
his belief that every party should only
have the smallest number of people
necessary to achieve its goal this way
everybody has a clear assignment and
they felt that their efforts were vital
to the success of the mission in 1901
Amundsen had a ship but still felt
unprepared to tackle the challenge that
sat in front of him he spent the next
two years making a trip to the waters of
Greenland to get acquainted with his new
vessel plus to test out equipment
provisions and the crewmen that he
intended to take on the expedition this
saps Amundsen's funds and against his
wishes he had to reach out to creditors
this was a problem that would actually
haunt some of the rest of his life
according to one version of the story
Amundsen and his crew had to sneak out
of Oslo and they started their mission
there's one of the creditors intended to
place the girl under Lynne until they
were repaid and other versions says that
fritti off Nansen a promise to take care
of the dirt while Amundsen was at sea
whatever the truth might be the girl set
sail on June the 16th 1903 headed for
the Northwest Passage the journey didn't
start off very auspiciously
in the early parts of the expedition
there was a fire in the ship's engine
room and the vessel almost shipwrecked
on an underwater rock after this however
things went a lot smoother as the Gir
crossed Baffin Bay ins then managed to
navigate the multiple tight straits of
the Arctic Archipelago some speculators
that Amundsen could have made the
crossing interest one season but
navigating of the Northwest Passage was
just one of the expedition's goals other
missions included collecting a ton of
scientific data and locating the new
position of the magnetic north pole for
this the crew needed more time so they
anchored in the natural harbour of King
William Islands and let the ship get
iced in fortunately for them the islands
had one human settlement called Oakes at
Oak which meant lots of fats in the
local language it was named because of
the abundance of seals in the area the
local Inuit people were happy to host
the Norwegian crew and showed them many
useful tips and techniques to survive
the freezing cold tips
Amundson took to heart and was later
employed during his conquest of the
South Pole the explorers spent almost
two years there before concluding their
objectives and also finding weather
conditions suitable enough to allow them
to leave internationally the settlement
is better known as Haven for the role it
played in making polar history there
were still more obstacles to overcome
though near the Yukon the ship got iced
in again worst of all while Amundsen
took a sled ride to Eagle Alaska to send
some telegrams one of his men gustav
Veeck fell ill and died on March 31st
1906 Amundsen later described him as the
happiest one in the group always full of
humor and stories who proved invaluable
to maintaining morale on the voyage on
the stranger side of things Amundsen
also found out on this occasion that the
nation and king that he served when he
left on the trip weren't the same ones
that were waiting for him when he
returns we've referred to role Amundsen
as being from Norway although
technically he was up until this point
actually a citizen of the United
Kingdom's of Sweden and Norway
ever since 1841 the two countries has
been in a personal union where they kept
separate constitutions and
administrations but were ruled by the
same king in a month since time this was
king oscar ii of sweden
however the nations underwent a peaceful
dissolution in 1905 so when Amundsen
returned home he returned to a fully
independent Norway ruled by King Rama
seven obstacles tragedies and political
movements aside the girl reached Nome
Alaska on August the 31st 1906
officially completing its navigation of
the Northwest Passage but just before we
continue with today's adventure let me
take a moment to tell you about today's
fantastic sponsor curiosity stream
curiosity stream is a subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles from
some of the world's best filmmakers
including exclusive originals now if
you're enjoying this one then you're
gonna find loads of stuff on that
platform all about exploration whether
that's learning Harry went to the moon
in the first place you can watch about
that in the Apollo moon landings or how
we're gonna go back in the aptly-named
series return to the moon but those are
just two great examples
many curiosity stream is available on
many platforms web app Roku Android Xbox
one Smart TVs iOS chromecast Amazon fire
Amazon Kindle Apple TV is also available
worldwide and I'm not going to name all
the countries get unlimited access
starting at just $2.99 a month and for
you guys the first 30 days are
completely free if you sign up a
curiosity stream calm /by graphics use
the promo code by graphics during the
signup process it's a great way to
support the show to keep us making more
videos and I really couldn't think of a
better fit for sponsorship given that
they're all about educational content as
well let's get back to it
[Music]
daring feats like crossing the Northwest
Passage might make you famous and
celebrate it but they won't make you
rich for the next couple of years
Amundson engaged in writing and giving
lectures to improve his financial
situation but he disliked these
activities intensely what he wanted was
to leave on another adventure not to sit
behind a desk but he had debts to pay
given his newfound fame
Amundson was having trouble finding
creditors willing to finance him what he
needed was a new plan that would stir up
public interest in 1908 II approached
the Norwegian Geographic society with a
proposition he wanted to take the Fram
the ship friedhof Nansen used in his
voyages and recreates the latter's
expedition to the Arctic Ocean this time
with better preparation and more modern
equipments this plan was received with
enthusiasm by the society by the public
and by the king he became one of the
first donors to a Munson's fundraising
campaign this was at a time when there
were multiple expeditions undertaken to
reach the North and South Poles American
explorer Robert Peary set a new farthest
north record in 1906 while British
adventurer Ernest Shackleton was just 97
nautical miles from reaching the South
Pole in 1909 although it wasn't
explicitly stated during the fundraising
it was widely believed that all Amundsen
would also make an attempt for the North
Pole perhaps becoming the first man to
succeed in reaching one of the most
remote points on the planet the plan
went down the drain in late 1909 though
when a news story it reached the
headlines Frederick cook a Munson's
former shipmate aboard the bélgica had
reached the North Pole his claim was
attacked by Robert Peary who also claims
to have reached the North Pole although
he did it slightly later this launched a
whole mess of arguments and
controversies that hasn't been
completely sorted even today Cook's
claim was dismissed by many not
necessarily as false but as being
unproven while Peary's was accepted but
with a lot of hesitation and many
experts have retro actively dismissed
his claim as well none of this mattered
in the moment though either one or both
or neither reached the North Pole but
the headlines said they did so all of a
sudden wasn't seen as the holy grail of
polar exploration anymore it had been
done which meant that interest in a
Munson's planned expedition started to
dwindle and the fundraising dried up
this was around the same time that
Shackleton tried and failed to reach the
south
Paul so Amundsen thought that maybe he
could still salvage the expedition by
changing his destination from the north
to the South Pole
he had strong competition another
British explorer Robert Falcon Scott or
Scott of the Antarctic as he later came
to be known had already made
preparations and announced his
intentions to sail for the South Pole
should at Shackleton not succeed his
party the Terra Nova expedition left
Cardiff in June 1910 on his ends
Amundsen had decided to make the switch
but did not tell anyone apart from a few
close confidants he was heavily in debt
and had to mortgage his own house to
fund the expedition after the newspapers
cancelled their sponsorships he knew
that only a sensational feat would help
him raise funds and that wasn't to be
found at the North Pole any more if he
went public with his new intentions he
risked having his expedition delayed or
cancelled altogether this would have
given Scott the best chance at
succeeding Allanson knew that he could
be criticized for this underhanded
tactic and indeed he was mainly he was
accused of entering a race against Scott
which was not only unscientific but also
endangered the men of both expeditions
the fram left Norway on August the 9th
eight weeks after the Terra Nova
expedition at this point most of the 19
crewmen aboard the ship still thought
that they were headed for the North Pole
it wasn't until they stopped madeira for
a few provisions that Amundson informed
them of his new plan and also wrote a
telegrams tell Scott as well the South
Pole expedition reached Antarctica in
January 1911 and set up a base camp on a
natural ice Harbor called the Bay of
Wales on the Ross Ice Shelf they named
this camp framheim station at one point
they even met a small party from the
Terra Nova expedition who was exploring
the area on the surface relations
between the two groups were cordial
although Amundsen later confessed that
he was relieved when he discovered that
the British crew had no wireless radio
as he feared they might have been able
to send word of their success first even
if he reached the South Pole before them
here was where a Munson's previous
experiences in polar situations as well
as the techniques he learned from the
Inuit people came into play he and his
men Warford skins like the Inuits
instead of the traditional heavy wool
clothing they subsisted on a meet ridge
diet as Amundsen observed during a stint
abroad the bélgica that it helped ward
off scurvy more importantly than all
Weejun it relied completely on dog sleds
and skis for transportation he brought
almost 100 Greenland dogs with him on
his trip as they could also be used for
meet along the way Scott on the other
hand had a certain aversion to using
dogs as he considered them unreliable he
employed a mixed transportation method
consisting of dogs Siberian ponies and
motorised sledges the sledges were
supposed to be the ace up his sleeve
except they were actually the exact
opposite first of all one of them they
lost while unloading the ship
furthermore they increased the cargo
load since the party had to carry fuel
for them but most importantly they
weren't capable of handling the extreme
weather and the others broke down early
into the trip
by comparison a Munson's journey was a
lot smoother although he too flirted
with the disaster once after months of
setting out the Frant home station a
party of age set off for the South Pole
in September 1911 this was done only to
get a head start on the British Amundsen
soon realised that they set off too
early and should have waited for the
polar spring for better weather
conditions they returned to France on
the way and several of the men were
sidelined with severe frostbite it all
led to an arguments between Amundson and
one of his officers Raja mal Johansen
who accused him of acting foolishly to
beat Scott unsurprisingly
a Hansen was left out of the next South
Pole party that departed a month later
this revised party only included five
men as well as 52 dogs and four sledges
the men were role Amundson Helmer Hansen
who had also been a part of his
Northwest Passage crew olive Virgil and
Oscar Whiston and severe hassel these
were the first men to reach the South
Pole thanks partly to finding a good
clear route on top of a previously
undiscovered glacier which Amundsen
named Alexei hayver glacier on December
the 14th 1911 the party arrived at the
destination they raised a little tent
that they named Paul Heim planted the
norwegian flag UNS left behind a lot of
ascot or whomever else may find it
should they fail to return they were
very diligent in their calculations
wanting to make sure that they had the
right spot and avoid a situation like
that between Peary and Kirk up in the
North Pole scott's party arrives a month
later on January the 18th 1912 and
Munson's team made it back to framheim
in late January and quickly began
packing everything up on the ship so
they could leave for Australia and send
word of their success of course Amundsen
didn't know it at the time but there was
no reason to hurry as Scott's entire
party had tragically died on the way
back
when he was home Amundson once again
began planning a drift expedition on the
Arctic Ocean like freeze off Nansen had
done before him he bought and fitted a
new ship named mortu but his plans were
put on hold by World War one
he eventually set off in 1918 but this
turned out to be his worst venture ever
problems kept cropping up the cause
delay after delay six years had passed
and the expedition had still not
fulfilled its mission Amundsen was once
again heavily in debt and all his
creditors had lost their patience with
him and they demanded repayment
including his own brother the Explorer
had no other choice
in September 1924 he declared bankruptcy
and lost his ship for a while it seemed
as if a Munson's adventuring days had
come to an end as he began giving
lectures in the United States to make
money however the opportunity for one
last hurrah presented itself in the form
of Lincoln Ellsworth a rich American
with an interest in polar exploration
Ellsworth was willing to fund more
expeditions to the North Pole as long as
he was a part of the group in the
previous years Amundsen had tried and
failed to fly over the pole but now with
Ellsworth backing he was ready to try
again first in 1925 Amundsen Ellsworth
and four other men took to dawnia Doge a
flying boats and almost reached 88
degrees north which at the time was the
northernmost latitude ever achieved by
plane there to stop shorts because one
of the aircraft's was damaged and had to
land however just a year later Amundsen
and a crew of 16 went aboard an Italian
airship called the Norge and
successfully flew over the geographic
North Pole assuming that both Peary and
cooks controversial claims of reaching
the North Pole were incorrect as well as
that of an American pilot named Richard
Byrd who also made a disputed claim of
flying over the pole this would be the
first of verified attempts of reaching
the geographic North Pole even if it
wasn't the flight still made Amundsen
and one of his trusted companions Oscar
Whiston the first man to travel to both
the North and South Poles in the ends
role Amundsen considered that this was
about as good as it got and he finally
retired although not for long just two
years later the 55 year old Amundsen and
a team of five boarded a laughs and 47
flying boat to assist in the search and
rescue of a crash - yet a Munson's
aircraft disappeared On June the 18th
1928 it is presumes that it crashed in
the Barents Sea
although
the bodies of Rolla Munson and his crew
were never found so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below do not forget to subscribe also
check out our fantastic sponsor
curiosity stream I'm linking to them
below and thank you for watching
[Music]